pour le voyez à beaucoup d'actualité
économique d'aujourd'hui et qui de mieux
que le ministre des finances hery girard
pour nous aider à voir plus clair
bonjour monsieur le ministre
bonjour alors beaucoup de gens voyaient
les rendements tout d'abord le dossier
de l'aluminium eaa le premier ministre
demande et une action forte de la part
d'ottawa alors on a annoncé des
représailles de 3,6 milliards de dollars
est ce que vous êtes satisfait oui bien
sûr il ya trois façons de résoudre ce
conflit il ya les négociations
politiques
c'est ce qui se passait depuis deux mois
et suez telles annonces d'hier il semble
que on doit utiliser d'autres avenues
bien sûr les représailles économiques
qui ont été annoncés aujourd'hui c'est
des mesures adéquates
il ya aussi les recours juridiques au
niveau de l'administration du commerce
américaine au niveau de l'organisation
mondiale du commerce
en vertu de l'accord de libre échange
cela dit la signature du nouvel accord
économique je me rappelle très bien on
avait déjà entendu les craintes de
l'industrie quels secteurs l'aluminium
n'était pas suffisamment protégé donc à
l'intérieur de l'accord et on le sait
aussi vous savez monsieur le ministre
avait classé home l'industrie laitière a
également dû faire des concessions
est ce que c'est le québec qui a fait le
plus de concessions avec cet accord la
hausse et a dit que l'aluminium aurait
aimé avoir des gains qui ont été faites
par d'autres industries l'acier
l'aluminium n'est pas défavorisé par
rapport à l'ancien accord nord américain
de libre échange il n'a pas été
suffisamment protégé peut-être mais
c'est à dire qu'on aurait aimé avoir
plus de protection mais il faut bien
comprendre que le marché de l'aluminium
dans l'américain est extrêmement
intégrés et l'enjeu de la compétitivité
de l'aluminium en amérique du nord
versus des producteurs asiatiques
c'est un enjeu qui comme un temps dans
le marché primaire qui est
majoritairement produit au québec que
dans les produits transformés
il ya tout un défi de compétitivité pour
l'industrie de l'aluminium nord amérique
il d'autant plus à en pandémie mais ce
qu'est ce que je faisais aussi c est ce
que le québec fait plus de concession
avec cet accord là là on l'avait vu
également aux sacs l'industrie mme
détient le québec comme un surplus
commercial important avec les états unis
alors le québec toujours bénéficier des
échanges commerciaux avec la libre
circulation des biens et des personnes
c'est au bénéfice du québec et c'est
pour ça on a toujours été les premiers à
dos et on monte à brian mulroney
les premiers à dos et la libéralisation
des échanges
et lorsqu'on regarde balançant le québec
est gagnant le québec 6 8 millions et
demi d'habitants
on a accès à un marché de 500 millions
de personnes ces accords si la situation
devait perdurer quel genre d'impact on
veut réussi parce qu'on sait les
alumineries puis l'industrie de
l'aluminium c'est principalement au
québec la wii mais ça dépend de
l'évolution de du prix mondial qu'une
prix est élevé plus c'est facile
d'absorber des hausses de nagisa mais
ouais ce qu'on voit présentement c'est
que le prix actuel et près de 18 % plus
élevé qu'il était au creux de la
pandémie qui est le moment où les
accusations de
de d'avoir augmenté l'offre sur le
marché nord américain
les récriminations du gouvernement
américain sont concerne la situation qui
prévalait avant l'augmentation du prix
présentement alors il faut être plus
compétitifs absorber ces roses de coûts
mais les grands perdants de settat les
flots ce sont les consommateurs avec un
et les entreprises américaines qui
transforme un minium dans certains cas
nous la revente l'exportent l'utilisent
je vous dirais que c'est carré flou sont
négatives pour l'ensemble de l'amérique
du nord
alors il faut discuter avec les
américains négocier et réussir à les
enlever et sol et les répètent les
représailles économiques et les recours
juridiques servent à faire permettre à
tout le monde d'avoir une conversation
assurément marché de l'emploi on l'a vu
ça s'améliore monsieur le ministre taux
de chômage 9,5 pour cent au québec est
ce que ça va plus vite que vous pensez
ce retour à la normale
ça va très bien savait que on a été
critiqué pour avoir des confiné trop
rapidement au on y la province
quelconque on finit le plus on a fermé
40% d'économies pendant près de huit
semaines
et lol et les les trois derniers mois au
niveau de l'emploi
on a récupéré plus de 70% des emplois
que nous avions perdu nous sommes à 94 %
du niveau d'emploi que nous avions en
février alors nous étions aucun emploi
alors le déconfinement se passe très
bien on continue le taux de
participation des femmes est beaucoup
plus élevé au québec que dans le reste
du canada onf est relativement mieux que
le reste du canada alors ça va bien dans
une situation qui est extrêmement
absolument cela dit peut-être cinq ans
ce sont tous des emplois à temps partiel
quand gall médecin mais ce n'est pas ça
qu'on veut la baisse et a dit que là
c'est parce que au mois de juillet on
est des cons finis les centres de choc
les restaurants non lieu partiel
associées à ces industries l'homme et
lorsqu'on regarde les gains de mai juin
juillet sur la caisse de dépôt et
placement qui fait moins bien
son indice de référence alors on a parlé
d'un rendement négatif c'est pas un
semestre qui va passer à l'histoire là
pour la caisse des dépôts
non on a des défis au niveau des
fondations
c'était déjà difficile avant la pandémie
et la pandémie a accéléré ses
difficultés lors aussi pas suffisamment
vous savez le marché boursier fait
beaucoup mieux que nous l'avions
anticipé dans les circonstances de la
plus grande récession recul et la
deuxième guerre mondiale mais n'ont pas
lire la technologie classique on a
appris aujourd'hui aussi le bruit et la
chambre on ne pas suffisamment des
grandes capitalisations technologiques
ont extrêmement bien et ça on a une
nouvelle direction
on les laisse s'installer on a un
nouveau directeur ou responsable des
marchés publics
ils vont avoir ce j'ai pleinement
confiance hall cela dit on a plusieurs
qui vont une bulle avec les valeurs
technologiques alors peut-être davantage
de prudence du côté de la caisse de
dépôt et placement actuellement l'a
écouté tout et quand vous êtes une bulle
je pense que le lait les nouvelles
technologies sont avec nous pour
longtemps laissé entreprises leur font
des profits
c'est certain que la valeur qui était la
captation boursière associés à ces
procès profil est extrêmement élevé mais
c'est pour l'ensemble du secteur
alors c'est des décisions en gestion de
portefeuille sont pas faciles de
référence on est soit surpondérer à sous
pondérer
mais il ya d'excellents renier ses
propos rien que ces compagnies de radier
d'excellence à se réveiller avec la
pandémie ça rajoute une couche en paraît
dix de risque est encore plus difficile
de voir plus clair même la prochaine
année merci beaucoup monsieur le
ministre d'abord est avec nous un
plaisir merci beaucoup merci